التقيت برئيس النظام السوري بشار الاسد
وركزت معه حول الاصلاحات لو تحدثنا عن ذلك
وكيف اخطا بتقدير انك مبعوث امريكي وليس
من فرنسا
استقبلني الرئيس بشار الاسد من الرئيس
شيراك وكان ذلك بعد الحرب على العراق
مباشره
والرئيس بالتشاور مع المستشار الالماني
ورئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين راى بانه بعد
الحرب في العراق كان من المهم ان نشير الى
شريك مثل سوريا بان الامور قد حركت
وبالتالي كان ينبغي ان تقوم سوريا بدور
اكثر نشاط في الحياه الدوليه شراك لذلك
قبل الحرف العراق حيث ان شراك كان مقربا
من حافظ الاسد والد بشار الاسد وقد راى
بان اعاده دمج سوريا على الساحه الدوليه
سيكون عاملا ايجابيا للمجتمع الدولي وكذلك
لسوريا نفسها وقد حاول ج
بشار الاسد يستقبله عدد من الشركاء
الاوروبيون
وكنا في وضع بعد الحرب ارسلني رئيس شراك
الى هناك واستقبلت استقبلت لساعات طويله
ام مع من قبل الرئيس شراك الذي رحب به
كثيرا قلت له من المهم ان تبادر نحن لا
نقول لكم ما هي هذه المبادره لانكم بلد ذو
سياده وانت الرئيس السوري القرار يعود لك
ولكن لتعلم اذا قمت بذلك سندعم اي مباراه
يمكن ان تدمجكم اكثر في المجتمع الدولي
عكس ما قيل فانني لم اقترح عليه ان يعيد
الجولان او زياره اسرائيل لان هذه مباراه
كانت
مستحيله وبدون جدوى وما كان علينا ان نقول
له ما عليه ان يبدو له ولكن كنا نريد منه
اشاره بانه يقوم بدور نشات ولكن قال
للرئيس
بشار هل الولايات المتحده هي التي ارسلتك
اذا كان من جانبه ربما توقع لزياره من
الامريكيين لم تتجسد وانتهت المحادثه على
هذا الاساس واستطيع ان اقول ان الرئيس
شيراك اسفه كثيرا لعدم وجود اي رد على
المقترح الفرنسي والالماني والروسي في ذلك
الوقت